[Musique]
pas si mal photo gd chroniqueur aussi
présent le témoigne jean-luc lemoine
vous n'êtes pas bien
vous n'êtes pas obligé de mettre une
photo il est là c'est pourquoi il a dit
oh my god matin vous préférez comment a
aujourd'hui on dirait on dirait un prof
de karaté à la baisse
mais pourquoi pas un prof de billard
ouais c'est vrai pourquoi de karaté mais
jean luc sans rigoler c'est vrai je vous
sur la veste on dirait les liaisons des
baisses comme ça jean de côle coeur
texas rangers mais il a pas il n'a pas
vieilli en tout cas beaucoup un peu
beaucoup non
non merci il est méchant sans gêne était
agréable et c'était pas méchant j'étais
marié sur six était champion j'étais
méchant réel c'est moi parce que vous
avez reçus et mais ce qui l'a ramené à
ma solitude mais regardez laura et non
un euro
l'achat grammaire et nora marion dumas
vous souvenez c'était l'époque de france
4 on s'en souvient john et on recevait
mireille dumas et après il y avait la
conférence de presse de france 4 on
était obligé de partir en deux filles
moi j'ai pas pu changer coup puisque je
m'étais fait la coupe mire et durable et
la photo est resté partout non mais là
tu te tais et des bois ne sont pas
possible vos téléchargements castaldi
l'a quitté la salle
attendez on a on à gilles verdez j'étais
jeune il n'avait pas les choses mais ça
mais vous êtes beaucoup mieux maintenant
bon dumbledore dans harry potter
regardez on a on aa on à gilles verdez
gêne à thierry mais bon il est parti il
est parti en turquie a jeté la baisse
jean marc bruel avait store ce qui est
il assez chaud il n'a pas bougé lui non
pas mal ouais ouais mais bon
géraldine maillet tient pas été six mois
sublime moi non mais c'est bien on a
fait aussi bien
et bien vous n'avez pas changé mais oui
oui un jour que ces vrais malades sont
découragés après on prend
[Applaudissements]
et toi tu leur as well as et on a vu
j'adore on dirait claire keim et ouais
ouais ouais bah merci
et alors on a on a également isabelle
morini-bosc alors c'est une photo noir
et blanc bien entendu comestibles
[Applaudissements]
c'était pour un magazine de charme ce
n'est pour aller jouer dans les manuels
je crois qui après cette faute dans mais
s'ils allaient ou c'est un saint c'est
jacky oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est la meilleure balle sorti depuis le
day la création attention les photos de
vous attendait d'abord chez mathieu
gallet chez vous pékin mais aussi au
banana café c1 c'est quoi c'est un
procès à ses instincts pour une expo je
sais plus positif c'est quoi des mois
alors de mémoire c'était un exposé sur
la peinture dessin d'ailleurs c'est
qu'ils ont bien fait c'est quoi le
banana café à la mode à la barre sympa
les parts de gâteaux faits oui je crois
que j'étais dans votre appel de six il y
avait des brésiliennes et tous fins
énoncés je vais vous livrer des balades
elle a cru qu'elle ait des jus de fruits
mais je vois là on était avec ma mère au
banana café
il faut savoir que daniel sa maman est
là qu elles achoppent maman 81,6 bientôt
ballon elle pourquoi pas sur moi bien
sûr l impression que traverse le miroir
parce qu'on vous regarde nous tous les
soirs donc j'ai vu trois pour la
première fois gilbert des en vrai il est
beaucoup plus beau qu'à la télé mesdames
là encore là
[Applaudissements]
elle a jeté son dévolu sur les tempes
grisonnantes
vous avez bien et en plus il a toutes
les zones
[Applaudissements]
elle adore votre maman je slynn ah ouais
je me disais aussi at elle pas le final
aurel jeu là c'est plus cher les hausses
entre embrasse major on t'embrasse
alors et donc pas voilà et on a des
photos de vous un rachat whissell a
toujours été dégueulasse moi c'est kader
a niées
le cape et d'épée alors on dirait un
coupeur de grecs suédois cité dans one
man show merci hawaï a pas y'a pas
d'autres non c'est bon merci ça suffit
celle là on dirait plus rhodia le patron
du chantier est dans la vérité si je
mens sans déconner quelle horreur arrêt
tissage assez intime bien je veux dire
je suis dégueulasse et je resterai
dégueulasse contre vents et marées vous
vous êtes pas pesé et oui je poserai au
lac